[Music]
on this Saturday night bracing for
recession
the latest warnings from economists
about an upcoming downturn affecting
everything from home prices to trick or
treat will there be as much Halloween
candy on those shows that we've seen in
previous years probably not
Coal Mine catastrophe an explosion in
Turkey kills dozens of miners sparking a
frantic rescue operation and claims the
Turkish government turned a blind eye
fertility funding when you experience
multiple miscarriages or a late loss
there's not just physical recovery
there's emotional coverage but
staggering costs facing those struggling
to conceive
plus jumping jellyfish but I called my
friend they were out on the boat and I
was like you guys need to come over here
this is insane Wildlife photographers
from around the world are rushing to BC
for an unbelievable bloom
global national with Faron Asser
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight in Turkey where a
small mining town is in mourning
following an explosion there that left
more than 40 people dead the blast
occurred late Friday night local time in
the port city of amasara that's some 300
kilometers north of the Turkish capital
Ankara 110 people were inside the mine
at the time of the explosion which is
now under a state investigation Reggie
zucchini has our top story
foreign
the sounds of ambulances pierced through
the air and Chaos as a frantic
hours-long underground rescue operation
was carried out in the town of amsara
along turkey's Black Sea Coastline a
fiery blast more than two kilometers
from the mouth of a coal mine and some
300 meters below the surface is now the
worst mining disaster in the country in
nearly a decade
110 of our brothers were working in the
mines as turkey's interior Minister some
of them on the upper levels managed to
exit right after this explosion there
were dozens of miners who made it out
alive their faces blackened with soot
Their Eyes heavy and grief stricken the
country's Health Minister posting a
video of people receiving medical
attention on site but as Dawn broke the
mine was still burning a plume of smoke
hanging heavy over the city
its mayor says several people were taken
to hospital some with life-threatening
injuries
but not everyone survived more than 40
people were killed and under Islamic
faith
funerals are already underway this man
whose son died says he started working
there in 2019. it would have been nearly
four years he says
Turkish president erdogan attended one
funeral and visited the site of the
blast
saying administrative and judicial
investigations are underway that will
reveal the reasons and who's responsible
it's believed this incident was caused
by a so-called fire damp a buildup of
gases likely methane an opposition
lawmaker says this state-owned coal mine
was flagged in 2019 as being at risk of
sudden gas discharge and fire burst
explosion increases
some trade unions argue profits took
precedence over safety less than a month
ago turkey's energy Minister posted
photos from the area as he addressed a
crowd of minors Dawning yellow hard hats
many of whom are now mourning the loss
of colleagues
we did not leave any of our friends
behind says this minor we have done our
last duty to our friends he says
Reggie Global News
turning now to the war in Ukraine Crews
there are working to restore power in
parts of the country after a missile
attack seriously damaged a Key Energy
facility near Kiev at least 10 missiles
also hit several locations in the
Southeastern city of zaparizia a parking
lot bore the full brunt of a Russian
strike destroying cars and nearby
buildings Ukraine claims a number of
missiles also struck residential areas
Russia is waging a campaign to destroy
Ukraine's energy infrastructure ahead of
the winter
those air assaults are part of what is
believed to be the largest coordinated
missile raid since Russia invaded
Ukraine back in February retaliation for
last weekend's Bridge attack in Russian
annexed Crimea NATO is now responding by
promising more military aid to Ukraine
and offering fresh warnings for Russian
President Vladimir Putin our Ottawa
bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson has been
speaking with one former NATO Ambassador
about these fast-moving developments
Mercedes Jeff on top of the very real
battles on the ground the war of words
between Russia and the West has entered
a new and jarring phase in recent days
Russia warned the West that admitting
Ukraine to Nato would cause a third
world war a defiant Vladimir zielinski
signed Fast Track papers to apply for
NATO membership in September but that
dream is likely years from being
realized since all NATO members would
have to agree to Ukraine joining while
immediate NATO membership is not in the
cards the traditionally soft-spoken
European Union has been stepping up its
verbal rebukes of the Russian Federation
saying the West would annihilate
Russia's Army if Putin goes nuclear in
Ukraine concerns that Russia could
launch a tactical Nuclear Strike have
been rising with U.S President Joe Biden
saying the risk of nuclear Armageddon is
closer than at any time since the Cuban
Missile Crisis I spoke about this with
former U.S ambassador to Nato Kurt
volcker who said the West Can't Ignore
Putin's threats but thinks the risk is
likely mitigated by Putin's own generals
who have heard the West's warning loud
and clear I think it's questionable
whether even if they were given the
order they would decide to deploy a
tactical nuclear weapon because they
know the consequences on themselves and
if they know that then Putin probably
knows that too and might be cautious
about giving an order that's not
followed wilker said individual NATO
countries like the United States and UK
have been digging deep to help Ukraine
defend itself but NATO as an
organization has deliberately held back
not wanting to risk feeding into the
perception that the alliance is at war
with Russia but NATO countries could be
doing more volcker says one critical
missing piece longer-range Munitions
that would allow the Ukrainian Army to
Target key Russian positions in Crimea
something Western countries have been
holding back from providing so far
Ukraine has been winning on the
battlefield in recent weeks retaking
significant swaths of its territory and
putting Putin and his army on the back
foot raising the prospect for Putin of
trouble at home they have tremendous
economic problems now because of the
global sanctions that have been put in
place they don't have the equipment they
don't have the spare parts even to give
to the soldiers that they're mobilizing
so this is just getting worse and worse
and the more he tries to keep going the
worse it is for Russia but Putin has
made it clear that he intends to fight
till the end and was no end of the war
in sight ukrainians are bracing for a
long difficult winter Jeff Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thanks Mercedes
you can watch the full interview with
Kurt volcker on the west block that's
tomorrow morning right here on global
government officials have confirmed to
Global News tonight that the Canadian
military has helped to deliver the first
batch of armored vehicles to Haiti this
video posted online shows a Canadian
military aircraft on the tarmac in Porto
Paz
Ottawa says six Vehicles were
successfully delivered today in
partnership with the U.S earlier this
week Canada's ambassador to the United
States called on both the U.S and Canada
to provide security assistance to the
country which is struggling to deal with
armed gangs that have blocked access to
fuel
turning to news closer to home now and
growing fears of an imminent recession
Canadians are already struggling to cope
with soaring inflation and Rising
interest rates and many economists are
predicting a mild recession will begin
in the first quarter of 2023. Sarah
often reports on the consequences for
Canadian consumers
the prospect of new Nikes is drawing
spend ready crowds to shoe stores so
they used to be ones like 60 on 70 now
they're 210. I agreed to buy them today
to then trade in another pair because
yeah money is tight in today yeah
recession fears may not be top of Mind
here but they are a concern among
economists who weren't a Slowdown could
be coming for 2023 when the cost of
living goes up everyone feels the
pressure right now we can certainly try
to release that pressure by reducing
um our spending but at the same time we
can only reduce our spending by so much
dos estimates food costs are up between
15 and 20 percent natural gas and
electricity costs could double this
winter and with many mortgage rates
coming up for Renewal the reality of
higher interest rates is expected to
weigh heavily I've never seen the same
Confluence of factors that I see now
that really push towards I think a
significant recession a significant
pullback insolvency rates are seeing a
sharp Rise by as much as 33 percent in
some provinces according to One debt
counselor people are finally feeling the
pain of the pandemic you know the two or
three years of you know extra government
support and creditors taking a back seat
even Canada Revenue Agency backing off
on their regressive collection
activities all that has really come to
an end and as Canadians move into the
holiday season the question is whether
warnings over a Contracting economy will
be met with tighter wallets eventually
it will be okay but it's just hard to
say when it will be okay and until then
unfortunately we will have to go through
this uh struggle some period definitely
budgeting definitely like worried about
like rent and groceries and everything
going up right so it's definitely always
in the back of our minds
but somehow we're still here buying
shoes Sarah often Global News Calgary
inflation and supply chain challenges
are also haunting trick-or-treaters
Halloween is just around the corner and
is Anne gaviola explains last minute
Shoppers for candy and costumes could be
left empty-handed
for the first time in a long time some
households are going all out for
Halloween anything that is getting the
kids extra enthusiastic right now is is
a gift after the last few years that
they had
Crystal westland's daughter Coco and
others in the neighborhood have big
plans I'm really really excited for
Halloween and Halloween in is probably
my favorite
um holiday we're planning on doing some
more cobwebs and we're going to decorate
our tree black and you know orange with
lots of spiders according to the retail
Council of Canada 86 percent of us are
planning to spend as much or more on
Halloween decor candies and costumes
this year as we did last year and with
inflation raging at multi-decade highs
many households are finding ways to do
more with less
a surge in demand coupled with lingering
supply chain snarls means selection may
not be as great as pre-pandemic will
there be as much Halloween candy on
those shelves that we've seen in
previous years probably not because the
manufacturing capacity isn't there right
now shipping and transportation costs
remain high and labor shortages are
everywhere all the manufacturers are
scrambling to ramp up their
manufacturing processes to make the
costumes all of this drives up costs to
Consumers households that are already
stretched financially may have to opt
out of Halloween or cut back
Karen clerkowski is reusing decorations
from years past it just all depends on
what I have in the cupboard what I
bought at yard sales or what I picked up
off the side of the road it's not about
the amount of candy it's the greeting
and the camaraderie and this the whole
feeling experts say creativity is key
finding these different ways to make use
of the resources that we already have at
our disposal is going to be good for all
of us it helps to reduce over
consumption it helps to reduce waste you
may find more tricks this year and less
treats and gaviola Global News Toronto
coming up caught in the Crackdown an
Iranian Canadian filmmaker is targeted
after criticizing tehran's tactics
foreign
welcome back as protests across Iran
enter their fifth week an
iranian-canadian filmmaker has become
the latest Target of an ongoing
Crackdown by Security Forces Monty who
Gigi says authorities prevented him from
leaving the country a move the filmmaker
links to his previous statements in
support of the widespread protests
across that country
perhaps the authorities thought that by
keeping me here they could keep a closer
eye on me perhaps to threaten me and
shut me up
well the very fact that I'm talking to
you in this video right now kind of
undermines that plan I cannot put into
words the joy and the honor of being
able to witness firsthand this great
moment in history
the London Film Festival where hagigi
was set to appear today says the
filmmaker had his passport seized as he
attempted to travel to London on Friday
hagigi was last in Canada just last
month for the premiere of his latest
film subtraction at the Toronto
International Film Festival
even amid that brutal Crackdown
Nationwide protests are intensifying yet
again with activists taking aim at
Iran's clerical leaders in Tehran parts
of that country's notorious Evan prison
were lit on fire today following what
officials call unrest fueled by criminal
elements now that facility holds
political Prisoners the situation there
is now under control according to
officials though Witnesses say they're
still hearing gunshots coming from that
area human rights groups say more than
200 people have now died in the
weeks-long demonstrations and that
situation is now being closely monitored
by Iranian expats here in Canada
Global's [ __ ] mosh Tahiti spoke to one
BC woman who fears the worst for her
family
every morning Port Moody resident Mehran
were not revealing her last name to
protect her identity anxiously watches
videos like this one on her social media
feeds
coming from her home city of sanandaj in
the Kurdish region of Western Iran and
every day Mehran wakes up with the same
fear yes I'm scared every single day I
just wake up I say oh my gosh I hope
today I we just go through it without
hearing any bad news
her home province of Kurdistan has been
one of the hardest hit in crackdowns by
the regime Amnesty International reports
that security forces are using firearms
indiscriminately
videos also emerging of Tehran sending
tanks to the city which belongs to the
same ethnic minority as Masa amini whose
death was a catalyst for weeks of
anti-regime protests
an audio recording of metron's call to
her niece in courtesan distorted for her
protection her niece panning her cell
phone camera to show her the violence
live I'm just watching it and witnessing
it oh my gosh what's going to happen
right now there is it like my my niece
is going to be shot and do you know what
they started to throw rock on all the
windows unlike in front of my eyes I was
just so horrifying for Mehran painful
memories come rushing back of when she
joined anti-regime protests in 1979
against the Islamic Republic I was in
exactly the same situation when I
witnessed my friends killed when I
witnessed my sister lost her leg when I
witnessed my brother killed we tattooed
freedom in our arm as for Mehran it's
Freedom that keeps her spirit alive
[Music]
and as for the people in her Homeland
during protests they sing and dance to
Kurdish music
an act that is illegal to show their
Defiance as demonstrators show no signs
of giving up negarmo Shahidi Global News
still ahead a Toronto mother raising
awareness about the unspoken side of
fertility
foreign
today Mark's pregnancy and infant loss
Awareness Day Karen Lieberman reports on
renewed calls for greater supports for
people struggling to grow their families
so when you saw that there was no
heartbeat in the ultrasound were you by
yourself was it during covid through her
podcast called day one and support
network Toronto mother Emily Goetz dives
into what she calls the unspoken side of
fertility I've gone through three rounds
of IVF most recently in January of this
year we conceived naturally fortunately
at eight weeks
we lost the heartbeat during her own
infertility Journey Getz has found
comfort in building Community an opening
conversation about an experience that
while common can feel isolating and
lonely acknowledging that they are going
through this
is the best way to find support one in
six Canadian couples experiences
infertility it was while carrying her
second child at 23 weeks that gets first
face this reality out of nowhere my
water broke we named her Ruby and that
really was like that sliding door moment
in our lives that got me to where I am
today very often fertility treatments
are required to help people avoid
recurrent loss when you experience
multiple miscarriages or a late loss
there's not just physical recovery
there's emotional recovery reproductive
endocrinologist and president of
fertility matters Canada Dr Ari baratz
is calling for improved and equal access
to fertility care for all Canadians half
of our provinces have some form of
financial support for fertility care
either locally or bursaries or grants
and then we have just as many that are
let's call it in the works baratz is
also asking more employers to consider
providing fertility benefits
so one day fertility care will be
treated like any other major health
issue Evan and I are still putting like
our best foot forward optimizing our
fertility
um and you know holding the belief that
that baby is is going to come to us
Karen Lieberman Global News
[Music]
next what's driving thousands of moon
jellyfish to North Vancouver's Deep Cove
[Music]
outdoor photographers in BC are being
treated to a rare site they're capturing
spectacular images of moon jellyfish Jay
Durant explains what's behind the bloom
not like coming all the way down here
something special is happening in the
water that has outdoor cinematographers
racing to this dock just off deep cold
I called my friend they were out on the
boat and I was like you guys need to
come over here this is insane right now
so right away you can see all of the
jellyfish a moon jellyfish bloom unlike
anything they've ever seen
all of a sudden you're in this
Amphitheater of floating jellyfish just
pulsating some are going up some are
going down they're just all over you
everywhere you look
you're basically swimming through this
jellyfish and they're bouncing off your
face and there's be times where you can
actually like move through them because
they're so thick
ding because there are thousands in
these Waters right now this warm weather
may have something to do with the bloom
jellyfish reproduction is often driven
by changes
um temperature in the water
this one looks quite a bit bigger than
what I've seen in many many years so it
was pretty incredible
these outdoor photographers have
traveled all over the world capturing
all kinds of incredible images
the rare opportunity to make a short
drive for an experience they'll never
forget I've seen some cool things I've
swam with whales I've skydived over the
blue hole in Belize but to have this in
our backyard is just insane
this is why Vancouver BC you know Canada
is such a absolute you know Paradise
country because you have all of this
absolutely amazing Wildlife so close to
where people live
Jay Durant Global News
and that is global national for this
Saturday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight
your Canada is chateauge Quebec thanks
for watching hope to see you back here
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]